let's go ahead and take a look at
building a resume
always exciting putting ourselves out
selling ourselves and if you looked at
some of our other videos dealing with
resumes you'll see a trend here
the top part is so different than what
resumes were in the 90s
uh in the 2000 to 2010
they've evolved they've really evolved
it used to be
2000 2010 maybe linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come into resumes
used to be that if you're a real estate
agent every real estate agent i knew i
used to deal with real estate software
for the real estate industry back in the
90s every real estate
agent won their picture on their
business card they wanted them
their picture if they could put on their
contracts
they want people to see the face so
that's really a big change is to make
sure that it stands out
you stand out here's a picture of
somebody so you're more than just a
couple letters and a name but of course
you need your contact information should
always be at the top
uh you have your summary what are you
focusing on
be a little careful with your summary
because if you have
everything in your summary and then they
scroll down to experience and education
and skills
they're going to stop the second you
repeat yourself in your resume
that usually means to the reader hey
this person doesn't have anything more
to offer me i'm done
so be a little careful how you word your
summary most
companies appreciate when you come in
here
and you've adjusted this summary to be
both about you
and how you're going to serve that
company so it's worth researching that
company to find out
how those connect and put that in the
summary take some time to do that
that's actually a pretty big deal and
the references are huge also
especially in data science when you're
talking about any of the programming or
data science data analytics
having a place to go where they can look
it up and scroll down
and see different things you're doing
whether it's linkedin in this case which
is the business profile most commonly
used
github we have stuff published facebook
i'm always hesitant because that tends
to push more towards
a social media type jobs and other jobs
but certainly there's people who have
facebook who do marketing and stuff like
that but these links
having these basic links here is
important people are starting to look
for that for
some other uh setup maybe you have a
personal website this is a good place to
put that so that they now have
a multitude of links that go back to you
and highlight who you are and then the
next part or next four parts
so for the next four parts we have a
combination of experience
education skills certifications
and you can see they're organized if you
have
you know a lot of people like to see
what kind of degree you have they want
to know where it came from
and if you just got out of college
you're going to put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom
if you've been in the field for years
you know my degree just to give you my
age goes back to the nine
early 90s so i usually put education at
the very bottom
and then because a lot of the stuff i'm
trying to sell myself on right now
is my skills i actually put that at the
top and i'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you
and sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image
probably don't wear an old tie-dye
t-shirt with holes in it
you know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again
when i put out resumes and i haven't
done a resume in a while
you go in there and you can take this
and reorganize this so if the company's
looking for something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company
you might even take experience if you
have like a long job history like i do
i've gone into a lot of different things
you might leave out those companies or
those experiences that had nothing to do
with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about
30 seconds to glance over maybe a minute
tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin
and they can now take this and they come
back to it and they go okay let's look
at this person a little closer
so quick overview this is your sell
sheet selling you
to the company so always tie it to the
company so that
you have that what am i going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here